willkommen bei der lieben freunde nach
mehreren monaten pause reagieren wir
heute endlich mal wieder auf ebay failed
hallo befehl dein letzte preis knie
nieder und zahle 170 euro du bist wo der
wort einfach nur produkte kaufen und
verkaufen warum müsste dann immer so
dumme jobs macht hallo darf ich fragen
warum nur abholung gruß ab hausverbot
bei der post
das können meine freundin sein weil sie
jeden tag 70.000 pakete bestellt ja
hallo ist noch zu haben man kann nicht
abholen ist doch zu haben mir passt es
fast immer außer morgen abend die
schneller der schrank weg ist desto
besser ach das ist in bonn tut mir leid
ich habe nicht gesehen ich wohne in nrw
bonn ist in nrw
die bfl allerdings wird ein limitierter
sneaker verkauf für 1000 euro und da
bekommt der verkäufer vor die nachricht
von einem potenziellen käufer und zwar
hallo ich würde gerne wissen warum
kostet denn so ein grotten hässlicher
schuh so viel geld danke mit
freundlichen grüßen das ist einfach
wahnsinn was komplett beleidigendes
sagen danke mit freundlichen grüßen habe
sie die liebe grüße ich bin viel zu
betrunken hallo ich will die playstation
gibt die playstation sofort guten tag
soll das etwa ein überfall seien ja okay
ich
warum ich so lange dass hier nicht
hochgeladen hey was könnte man am preis
ändern hey was bietest du an hey lass
mich in ruhe ich
frag mich ob wirklich nichts mehr
nächstenliebe feld verschenkt jemand ein
ikea canucks regal und ein potenzieller
käufer fragt hallo ist da die kommode er
ist der
einfache jobs durchgespielt und ebay
verkauft jemand gebraucht tragen die
auch immer man das formulieren mag und
ein interessent fragt den hai stinken
die nikon sehr nein überhaupt nicht ok
schade
strafft ich mal einfach mal ein fetisch
auf schuh gestank abend menschen
abstoßend hier wird auf jeden fall eine
wohnung lebt lenovo thinkpad 56 520 y
000 t bruder
ende macht echt perfekt einfach ihr
iphone 11 10 oder 12 kanal was gerade
ist aber einfach zahlen
oder auch auf test damit den autos im
model die gibt's gar nicht drei models
mode liegt keine ahnung wie oder keine
ahnung wie alle wirklich alle machen es
richtig aber was ist was machen diese
ganzen computer hersteller denn
1000 verschiedene sachen pc de vence des
mercedes
g500 de
waal bruder einfach mit jetzt 123 auf
jeden fall fragt jemand bei diesem
lenovo thinkpad also irgendwie eine art
ipad glaube ich ist sky inklusive 10
fragezeichen und wie lange wieder zehn
fragezeichen natürlich nicht was das
denn für eine saudumme frage warum
schreibst du es denn rein doom olaf
stier
jackson mensch egal
sind dafür rotzlöffel auf ebay 10 euro
kommen holen heute ist weihnachten frohe
weihnachten nein danke schlechten
rutschung hässliche weihnachten betritt
das war muss ich noch mit dem nächsten
jahr verkauft die man auf jeden fall
einen frechen hamster ich habe keine
ahnung was das sein soll allerdings
schreibt jemand guten morgen wir
interessieren uns für ihre anzeige und
wollten uns informieren ob er noch ein
schönes zuhause sucht mit freundlichen
grüßen sind sie menschen die ich bin
nashorn und meine freundin ist ein
regenbogen einhorn
das verstehe ich auch nicht die dummen
gegenfragen ich würde aber auch doch
noch eine andere person kennen die
glaube ich demnächst mal ein hamster
braucht man allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten gipfel und zwar sucht dort eine
person im auto denn man kann auch er
nicht nur sachen kaufen verkaufen keine
ahnung was sondern man kann auch eine
anzeige schreiben von denen ich suche
das und das hat das vielleicht gegen die
jemand und daraufhin hat ihm eine person
geschrieben und zwar moment warum sucht
man so ein hässliches auto das können
sie sich doch bestimmt selber
beantworten scheint haben sie auch
danach gesucht stimmt habe ich nicht
nachgedacht mit freundlichen grüßen
kann ganz gekonnt das eigentor
geschossen hallo geht wird sie 300 euro
paypal 300 ist zu wenig wie viel wäre
okay würden sie antworten ich starre nun
seit einer stunde aufs display
es gibt mir eine freundin sollen im
nächsten jahr verkauft einem personen
nike air max 790 er in schwarz-weiß
größe 46 meine größe ich neben spaß
beiseite freunde es gab auf jeden fall
interessenten und er den verkäufer
gefragt hey noch da
was für joberhalt ich scheiße oder
was sind das hierfür chat verläufe sehen
euro abholer 15 euro ok
aber dafür kriege ich noch ein bonbon
als über kennt ihr noch bum bum ist das
hier
herbst gast
das war mit abstand das ekelhafteste eis
der welt es ging nichts über
flutschfinger
capri und magnum mandl ich habe immer
gern eure lieblings 18 runden die
kommentare wenn es keiner von den dreien
ist die abonnieren ich mal ganz schnell
dann nämlich wäre verkauft seine person
allerdings einen e-scooter ich habe
schon mal ausgemalt hat jetzt ihre
wunden ich habe ihr die wunde ich habe
hier begonnen lange rede kurzer sinn
jemand verkauft auf jeden fall sein
erster auf ebay was die einzig richtige
entscheidung ist
ich habe im letzten sektor um den
wahrscheinlich auf insgesamt gesehen
ich habe nur
23 aussenspiegel gefahren ist aber auch
egal auf jeden fall verkauft die man
sein scooter auf ebay
dabei gibt es da überhaupt interesse
dran du kannst du doch will
ein-euro-jobs okay auf jeden fall sogar
auf dem an diesem schalter und eine
person hat interesse schreibt daraufhin
okay ich würde es gut oder direkt über
ebay bezahlen und morgen abholen okay
nur bitte sie kommen denen ja sowieso
abholen dann leg mich
ja ich würde gerne das ist hier nicht
bezahlt was einfach das beste eis hier
verschenkt die man einen silbernen
wäscheständer auf ebay und eine person
fragt haye noch zu haben
und sie möchten dafür nichts haben
sorry bisschen teuer
den 25 auch drauf gehen wir nicht über
schenkel nächsten wer viel verkauft wie
man alte spielzeug krims krams alte
möbel alles mögliche und ein interessent
fragen und tag ist er schaut noch zu
haben ich würde das alles auf einmal
abholen ich habe einen großen ich habe
auch einen großen okay okay
okay
nintendos wii inklusive vp wäre mir das
ovg für online vertragspartnerschaft
steht
und dass wenn man beispielsweise eine
playstation kauft das man direkt online
mitgliedschaft bekommt alles koste was
es
auf jeden fall schreibt ein interessent
für 250 euro wäre ich dabei und kann das
geld gern direkt überweisen liebe grüße
295 will der verkäufer allerdings haben
und daraufhin entgegnet der interessent
stirbt
ich glaube die werden sich nicht mehr
ohne konnte nur sagen es auch schon zum
letzten mal fällt für heute und zwar
schreibt eine person hallo ich bin
interessiert schreiben sie bitte letzter
preis gruß paul letzter preis
danke ihr
werden seit sieben monaten wieder wenn
ich den nächsten teil von ebay feld
machen
[Musik]
klickt einfach hier das video an oder
abonniert
und vielleicht besser auf die werbung
klicken dann kann ich hier
ein bisschen öl kaufen